We ended the last video with the Kingdom of Terror,
which began in April 1793 and lasted until July 1794,
where Robespierre ended up in the guillotine.
So it seems that France had overcome the heaviest period of the Revolution.
In the same way, the French themselves have understood.
Then we pass in 1795.
France is able to withstand wars with
most of Europe.
And peace has been declared with Prussia and Spain.
Peace with Prussia and Spain.
So the two main enemies that remain are
Great Britain and Austria.
So slowly, France faces its enemies.
First of all, this was a victory for France.
So France is the winner with the big number
of the civilian army he has created.
All this happened in April 1795.
Then in August of the same year 1795-let me do it in another color-
in August 1795 in the new republic
the constitution was approved.
And it is passed through the votes of the people, which
makes France officially a republic.
They no longer need a king.
And regulated the structure of the government where the executive
consisted of five leaders.
Thus the executive is called the "Leader"
So you did not have a president,
but five leaders.
Five leaders.
And then the legislature, and this is important because
this was the first "two chambers" legislature for France, which it had
"two houses" - (as a legislative body)
There was a Council composed of 500 people, which is the same as that of the United States.
The House of Representatives.
Which had 500 members in it, 500 representatives.
Let me write it down.
was "two-room".
There were two houses, the same as the US Congress.
And the Council composed of 500 people.
Then you had the "Old Council, with 250
representative.
All this, if you want to look at it from the US point of view,
which was the same with the US Senate.
And the "leader", the leaders, the candidates
from the "500 Council" were submitted to the Council
Old people, who then chose five executives-five
the people who would be leaders in France.
So far, it is seen that things are going well.
Yet, even though they had military victories, again
were concerned.
There were still monarchists there.
Still, Great Britain was still causing problems.
Great Britain is attacking the western regions of France.
Monarchists were found everywhere in Paris.
Then, in October 1795, a Monarch was planning revolt.
And the monarchists were the ones who wanted to
restored royal power.
Or they were against the revolutionary government.
And to a higher degree, they were not just bored of
the fact that there was no royal power.
They were also bored of the fact that
were excluded from the "Leader"
Thus they expelled the monarchists.
Even before creating the 'Leader' of broader routes,
Monarchists were revolting in Paris.
Monarchists were revolted in Paris.
And they fired the Tuliites.
This is the same place if you have remembered earlier,
some videos earlier, where the King and the Queen were
in house arrest. And later they were attacked by
the revolutionary government.
It was this painting here.
It was only three years ago.
That was in 1792 when they got
The King and the Queen as prisoners.
And they executed Luigi 16 alone
after a few months.
Now everything was heading in the other direction.
Rather than the monarchists were with the Tuliers, and
surrounded by revolutionaries, revolutionary government
it was with the Tulims and were rebuilt by the Monarchists.
In fact, the situation did not look good for
the revolutionary government.
They were few in number.
It seemed that the monarchists were better in number.
But fortunately for the revolutionary government,
there was a young, very ambitious, very selfish,
military commander who had observed
Tulier's siege when Luigi 16 and Marie-Antoinette
were caught.
At the time, he had marked it in the head.
He had said that they would only stop besieging if he would
they had good artillery.
Considering that he had been artillery commander.
Thus began to become famous.
In the Toulon Siege he was able to use artillery
effectively to suppress a revolt.
In fact, he was watching this scene three years later.
And now, in 1795, where the revolutionary government is with
The firemen and monarchists are ready
take power, Napoleon, using it
who had learned to look at it at the first time, was capable of
put balls and artillery in the right way.
And he fired so they called "grapeshot".
It was as if a singer came from a canon.
Although they were significantly few in number compared
with the monarchists, he was able to fight
pushing with balls.
Even though you had more numbers, you did
all these carps.
Let me draw you one.
You had a carpal and the ammunition would contain these
small bullets.
That is why it is called "grapeshot", it looked like
bunch of grapes.
And after the shot, it would go in all directions.
You can imagine, kill, whoever it was
in the same direction as the carambola.
Thus Napoleon was able to save
the revolutionary government.
And let the "Leaders" get the power.
So again, Napoleon was in the right place and
at the right time.
And he was very capable of military tactics.
He was selfish, narcissistic,
but she knew very well what she was doing.
And so Napoleon was becoming more and more famous.
This event, on October 5, 1795 where Napoleon is capable of
revolve the revolutionary government, this is also known as
"13 Vendemiaire"
I know I'm wrong.
Still, that was the month of October at
New French Revolutionary Clare.
You appreciated Napoleon more as a national hero, or even
hero revolutionary.
People are beginning to understand this man, eventually
I know what you are doing.
But you can imagine at the same time, "Leader"
he really did not want this man to stay so close to him
the waters of power.
It seems he was ambitious.
Obviously he was competent.
In a way, it must be a threat
for "Leader"
So they give him power.
But they ensured that he would stay as far away from France.
Thus he was placed at the helm of the organization
campaign for Italy.
So Napoleon was put in charge.
Remember, we are still fighting Austria and Great Britain.
So we are fighting Austria in Italy.
And Napoleon became Commander of
Italian forces.
And he's incredibly successful.
This was the least important front of the war
with Austria to this point.
But of all the generals of the various fronts,
Napoleon was the only one to show that
was extremely innovative and versatile and
in the end a good general.
So Napoleon was "telling pleasure" to Italy.
Napoleon in Italy.
And yet, he was starting to become more and more famous,
increasingly known.
Eventually, Austria admits it will not
defeat France.
They are looking very good for us.
And they make peace with France in October of 1797.
The Italian campaign ended in 1796.
So he defended
the revolutionary government in 1795.
He "shows his pleasure" in 1796 to Italy.
In 1797 it is in peace with Austria.
So only Great Britain remains.
But this peace with Austria will be in fact
very short.
This is from the Campo-Formio Treaty.
Let me write to you.
And yet it was peace with Austria.
But France was the winner.
So this is another victory of France.
And the only true enemy remained Great Britain.
But the main problem was that Great Britain had
the dominant marine fleet in the world.
So France, and especially Napoleon, was not ready
to face the UK in the water.
And that was somehow a controversial decision.
In 1798 - and if you keep in mind, "The Leader" did not really like it
Napoleon would stay in France.
They were like: you are very famous, you are one
good general, you are a great general.
Go do what you want.
Whatever you think is right.
Thus Napoleon attacks them to attack Egypt.
And people were not 100% sure which was the main strategy
of the purpose of attacking Egypt.
So in 1798, he leaves Toulon.
If you keep in mind Toulon was the port where he helped print.
He leaves Toulon on the way to Malta.
And then eventually, he arrives in Egypt since
take control of Egypt.
And people believed that he wanted to conquer Egypt
so that, to achieve
Britain through India.